ich würde gerne über das thema flucht
und migration sprechen und nicht nur
deswegen weil es im wahlkampf überhaupt
keine rolle gespielt hat was mich
äußerst verwundert zurück gelassen hat
und übrigens auch nicht in den
sondierungen und koalitionsgesprächen
die uns jetzt demnächst erwarten nein
aus mehreren gründen wir haben neue
fluchtrouten nach europa die direkt vor
deutschlands grenze oder auch in
deutschland enden über weißrussland und
über moldawien zweiter hat die akzeptanz
in der bevölkerung unter den nachbarn
dort wo flüchtlingsheime gebaut werden
rapide abgenommen gegenüber diesen
gebäuden in denen flüchtlinge
untergebracht werden und drittens lassen
wir andere für uns mauern mauern und
zäune nämlich jetzt zum beispiel die
polen oder die baltischen staaten und
das ist irgendwie nicht fair
er schob ich direkt die frage ansehen
was würden sie denn als lösung
vorschlagen also wasser deutschland es
gibt keine lösung aber wir sollten
aufhören darüber zu schweigen wir hatten
in der unterschied zu 2015 ist doch dass
wir damals einen großen ansturm von
flüchtlingen und migranten hatten wir
erinnern uns alle und das führte zu
erheblichen verwerfungen in deutschland
natürlich ganz klar weil sich da die
fronten gebildet haben die einen haben
am münchner hauptbahnhof hurra gerufen
und die anderen haben ganz große angst
bekommen und dann hat sich die
gesellschaft darüber immer weiter
gespalten eine ganz natürliche
entwicklung
ob sie gut oder schlecht war weiß ich
nicht jetzt aber haben wir doch etwas
ganz anderes jetzt wird die ganze
entwicklung ignoriert ich nenne nur mal
ein paar zahlen wir haben eine
flüchtlingsbewegung aus weißrussland
seit dem frühen sommer da kamen im
august 600 nach deutschland im september
2005 100 und in den ersten beiden wochen
des oktober schon 2600 also eine
exponentielle kurve und wir haben ja
alle gehört dass die weißrussische
regierung dafür sorgt dass die menschen
ohne visum nach kiew fliegen können nach
nach in die hauptstadt von weißrussland
fliegen können und dann zur grenze
gebracht werden -
die andere route führt über moldawien
die geht direkt nach berlin asylbewerber
die gar kein asyl bekommen werden in die
hauptstadt transferiert und bekommen
hier bargeld auf die hand ich kann auch
dieses problem nicht lösen wenn ich eine
lösung vorschlägen soll schlagen sollte
wäre es die dass wir erst mal damit
aufhören
asylbewerbern die hier ankommen bargeld
leistungen zu gewähren weil das
natürlich auf jeden fall als magnet
wirkt das übrigens auch eine forderungen
die die cdu zumindest in berlin gestellt
hat und dann müssen wir uns die frage
stellen ob wir weiterhin so mit den
außengrenzen der eu umgehen können dass
die entweder offen sind oder dass wir es
dem jeweiligen land überlassen so wie
jetzt zum beispiel polen das für 335
millionen euro einen eine mauer baut und
sie dann damit alleine lassen also da
hat aber auch gerne mal den politikern
der runde fragen dagegen aus also oder
sagen sie sagen sie ja sagen sie was das
was sie da zu denken tatsache ist ja
dass alle die nach europa kommen nach
deutschland wollen da müssen wir uns
nichts vormachen
ich persönlich glaube dass wir in dieser
debatte viel zu oft angst vor der afg
haben und wir brauchen diese angst nicht
zu haben sondern wir brauchen eine klare
linie und die klare linie muss sein
humanität und ordnung zu sagen wir sind
anders als die afd weil wir eben sagen
wir machen das nicht wie einige von
denen man könnte die auch ertrinken
lassen dem mittelmeer wir machen es
nicht so dass wir humanitäre
katastrophen produzieren sondern wir
sorgen dafür dass es vernünftige
aufnahmezentren an der europäischen
außengrenzen und erika das einfach als
wir dass wir am ende aufnahmezentren an
der europäischen außengrenzen haben die
auch vernünftig finanziert sind und da
fängt das ganze an sie sagen man würde
das kann man würde dafür sorgen oder man
würde die arbeit andere machen lassen am
ende ist das glaube ich ein
gesamteuropäisches projekt und wir
müssen dann eben in diesen zentren das
europäische asylverfahren ist
weitestgehend verfahrens weitestgehend
europäisiert dann eine vorprüfung dort
vornehmen und am ende dann auch von dort
auch schon zu entscheiden haben
diejenigen eine bleibeperspektive
langfristig oder haben sie sie eben
nicht da muss die entscheidung getroffen
werden das muss am ende das salz ist es
also hatten wir glaube ich hinkommen und
am ende auch eine klare linie vorgeben
und manja sieht und ort was mir ganz
klar ein bei der 13 blick
in die runde ich da so vielen dank
natürlich
weil ich teile die sorge von von gunnar
schupelius das hat fast schon skurrile
züge angenommen wie man das thema
migration migration asyl haus auch
steigende kriminalität unter den in
deutschland lebenden ausländern vor
allem auch mit flüchtlings angeblichen
flüchtlings hintergrund wie man das
einfach ausgeklammert aus den gründen
die
die sicht haben die öko bauern das leben
man angst hatte applaus von der falschen
seite aus zu lesen aber die tatsache ist
doch einfach wenn wir die wirklichkeit
anschauen stellen wir da einfach fest
und ich glaube viele leute in
deutschland würden das ähnlich sehen das
in diesem ganzen migrations und
asylbereich ein riesiger betrug
stattfinden das den leuten irgend etwas
vorgegaukelt etwas nicht stimmt dass man
ihnen sagt das seien alles an leib und
leben bedroht der menschen flüchtlinge
nach genfer konvention was nicht stimmt
sind der großteil der leute über 90
prozent sind leute das wirtschaftlichen
gründen ihre kommen da hat man auch
verständnis selbstverständlich kommen
jeden nachvollziehen aber wir haben
einen rechtsstaat und der rechtsstaat
sagt asyl flüchtlinge dass sie nur die
die ganz bestimmt ein wirtschaftsklima
ist ja wie müsste man mit den leuten
sprechen wie es mit dem ikrk aussprechen
ist mit den leuten die in diesen 100
zentren arbeiten sprechen
besteht dass jeder der heute jeder
migrant der heute eine kleine grenze
übertritt in die europäische union wie
quasi automatisch zum flüchtling erklärt
kann hierbleiben und das problem ist
einfach dass man dieses problem
tabuisiert man möchte nicht darüber
reden jeder möchte ein guter mensch sein
aber wichtig ist wenn man keinen rex
rechtsextremismus will wenn man nicht
möchte dass es irgendwie brot oder in
der bevölkerung da muss man geordnete
migrations verhältnisse handel frage ob
monika einer reihe einordnen kann ich
will dass weniger leute aber den
faktencheck zu der zahl 90 prozent
werden wir selbstverständlich
nachliefern in einer der kommenden
sendung ich habe dann aber eine frage an
herrn kuban und zwar das thema
tabuisierung und angst vor der afd
glauben sie dass das im osten einer der
großen gründe war warum die fdp zu stark
ist und warum die cdu dort auch so sehr
verloren hat
das ist ein thema aber es nur darauf zu
fokussieren wäre auch zu einfach da muss
man sich glaube ich auch ehrlich machen
da gibt es das ist ein thema wo wir doch
wissen dass es viel viel weniger
menschen mit migrationshintergrund in
den neuen bundesländern im osten gibt
und deswegen ist nur daran festzumachen
ist ein bisschen zu einfach und ich
finde das würde auch der ganzen debatte
nicht gerecht werden deswegen würde ich
das nicht so stehen lassen die frage ist
ja eigentlich nicht herr köppel ob das
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge sind oder nicht
das können wir gar nicht klären das wird
ja durch das asylverfahren geklärt das
problem ist doch nur dass wenn die leute
dann einmal hier sind und kein asyl
anspruch bekommen wie zb bei den
moldawien die zu 100% keine bekommen
dass sie dann hier bleiben und jetzt
kommt die frage wie verlassen sie dieses
land wieder wenn sie es nach dem gesetz
müssten oder wenn sie sich anstrengen
nach per gesetz gehen ist deutschland
oder die schweiz wir sind wir teil des
schengen raums wir sind teilt ist dass
dublin flüchtlings abkommens und im
doppel in der flüchtlings aufkommen
steht drin dass sie keinen asylantrag
stellen können wenn sie durch einen
sicheren drittstaat gekommen sind jetzt
wenn sie nach deutschland kommen wollen
dann sind sie wenn ich die außengrenzen
richtig beurteilen immer durch einen
sicheren drittstaat gekommen also müssen
sie sich die frage stellen sind also
auch diese
asylbewerber sind die mit dem helikopter
gekommen mit dem flugzeug oder
abgesprungen aus der luft und da fängt
der betrug schon an dass man das dublin
flüchtlings abkommen nicht ernst nimmt
und das empfinde ich habe seinen kann
man doch auch nicht sagen dass wenn die
griechen und italiener die ganze zeit
mit einem problem alleine ein aber ich
nicht reden aber dann sage ich ihnen
dann müssen sie auch zugeben dass diese
ganze eu migrationspolitik
ein schwindel ist weil wir weil das ist
genau die situation dass die italiener
und die griechen im grunde die
außengrenze sichern müssen und wenn ein
migrant in italien den boden betritt und
einen asylantrag stellen würde dann
dürfte er nicht in der schweiz oder in
deutschland einstellen nur das machen
die italiener nicht die geben den leuten
dort natürlich war die st wir schicken
sie hoch das ist einfach die realität
die können sie tot schweigen sie können
eine ausblenden was damit die reale die
schweige nicht die realität tod ich gebe
ihnen vollkommen recht dass es so ist
aber das problem ist doch wir haben vor
2015 doch auch fehler gemacht haben wir
mal gesagt dass es irgendwie weit weg
dass es irgendwo da in lampedusa und das
interessiert uns alles und dann haben
wir 2015 das erste mal gemerkt
die kommen ja sogar jetzt auch zu uns so
und dann haben wir angefangen uns sagen
oh dublin dublin dublin geschrieben und
das ist mir am ende auch ein bisschen zu
wenig wenn wir über europäische
solidarität sprechen dann sollten wir
auch da unsere solidarität gerecht
werden und klar machen dass wir ja weil
man kann nicht einfach nur sagen die
italiener sollen mit dem problem allein
gelassen werden
[Musik]